Speaker 2: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192.
David P this some of you might like this.
The San Antonio troll has come out of the
woodwork and he is once again slamming me
for things I never said and that I don't believe.
We have been hearing from the San Antonio
troll for years and one of the hallmarks of
the calls to our voicemail number from the
San Antonio troll is that he will slam me
and criticize me for things that he must have
either made up altogether or heard on a different
show, because they don't reflect in any way
things that I've said on this program.
This is an exact example of that here.
The San Antonio troll slams me for the things
I said and the things I believe about the
Ron DeSantis Martha's Vineyard stunt.
He's just confused.
And for those of you who listen to other progressive
shows, let me know if you can tell who he
might actually be talking about.
Speaker 3: ASMAN It is the, uh, your dear
old friends.
Um, I'm from Texas, and I saw you flip out
about this story where oh, my God, I heard
you just before this year.
Speaker 2: Wasn't this show I wasn't flipping
out at all.
Speaker 3: Um, I think it's funny.
You're flipping out and getting kind of a
little tricky.
And it's funny to say the, you know, the great,
rich, wealthy people of Martha's Vineyard
already deported these people.
Speaker 2: So it's not a deportation when
you go to a different state, first of all.
And secondly, as I've talked about earlier,
Martha's Vineyard is a tiny island with very
few jobs and even fewer jobs.
Off season, there's a few hotels and, you
know, a couple stop and shops there.
There's very little to do.
So there's just no jobs there for the.
I mean, this whole concept of deportation
is crazy.
Speaker 3: And you.
Speaker 2: But and by the way, the last before
today and this voicemail was left over the
weekend, I hadn't even talked about the immigrants
leaving Martha's Vineyard.
So this couldn't possibly be about anything
I said.
Speaker 3: But you've always been in favor
of open borders.
You and all of a sudden.
Speaker 2: Not not this show.
As many of you know, I have never been in
favor of open borders, as I have said before.
We need a path to citizenship for those who
came here as minors and are still here.
And this is really their home.
We need immigration reform.
The wall is pretty dumb.
I have never been for open borders.
In fact, there are people in my audience to
my left who do want open borders.
And I've said no countries are allowed to
have a border and to enforce it, but let's
do it in a way that makes sense.
Speaker 3: And then it's.
This proves my point of liberalism.
You everything is the moral high ground with
you.
You are that you're moral.
All.
We should let everybody in.
We should give this to everybody.
Speaker 2: That's never been something I've
said.
Speaker 3: Do this.
Nobody should care.
You real good.
It's very easy to take these.
The holier than thou positions when you live
2000 miles away.
Speaker 2: Yeah, not positions I've taken,
but talk to somebody who maybe has taken the.
Speaker 3: Assault tack than 2000 miles away
in your big double gated community with armed
security guards at the ready.
Very easy to say.
Hey, let everybody into our borders.
Speaker 2: Yep.
Okay.
So anyway, I've never said let everybody in.
Very, very confused individual.
Here's my request.
I am more than I'm willing.
I'm interested in receiving critiques of my
views being corrected.
I issue corrections, all of that.
But call in and talk to me about something
I've said.
That's my that's my request.
All right.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 1: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 2: All of Puerto Rico is without electricity
as Hurricane Fiona has made landfall.
I hope.
That Joe Biden's response to this hurricane
is going to be better than that of Donald
Trump during Trump's term.
We're going to talk about it.
We are going to talk about the special master
assigned to review the documents taken from
Trump's Mar a Lago.
His name is Raymond Dearie.
We'll tell you all about him.
And we are also going to talk about Gavin
Newsom, the governor of California, challenging
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis to a debate
after migrants were sent to Massachusetts,
as we have extensively covered.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Don't miss it.
Sign up at joined topman dot com and I'll
see you there.